so last time we talked about the
generalization bonds and today we are
going to talk about
um uh some better generalization bonds
for these Networks
so recall that last time what we did was
that we show something like the rather
macro complexity
is bounded by something like this
times and polynomial
of the norms
of the the weights
right so
and we said that this comes from a kind
of a worst case bond for
ellipsislessness
um of the
of the model
um
foreign
over the entire worst case over the
entire input space
and this is because when we do the
covering number we have to use this
Ellipsis decomposition this lipsticks
composition level and and there you have
to
um use the
um uh you have to use the lipstickness
for the entire set
so this is a little bit distracting in
the in the in the life just because I'm
sharing the screen using my laptop so
that you can charge my iPad
um okay so and we have discussed a few
motivations for us to improve upon this
uh theorems right so I guess we
discussed four of them and one of them I
guess I'll just briefly mention them in
words one of them is that you know this
bond is exponential
um
exponential in depth
which is bad because typically you have
a lot of players and another thing is
that you know this is worst case
lupusiousness and one another thing is
that typically you want to have
something like
um
SGD prefers
um Ellipsis models
that's good but this is Ellipsis models
you know and where Ellipsis is on the
empirical data
because if you think about an algorithm
and an algorithm can only do something
on the empirical data right so you know
so we'll show this more like later in
the course but even if you think about
it right so like on a high level right
so the algorithm can only prefer
something about empirical data but not
about the entire space
right and and and also we said that for
tighter Bond we're going to have
something of data dependent right
something that depends on the lips on
the empirical data so concretely I guess
today we're going to do is that we are
going to show something like this the
generalization of parameter Theta is a
function
of lusciousness
of f Theta
on the empirical data X1 after X and
and also the norm
of theta and this function is a
polynomial
so that there is no any exponential
dependency there's no Paradox of things
so so that's the goal of this lecture
and we're going to call it so
and we we have to do like the
we have to Define some kind of like I'll
introduce some new Machinery to achieve
this kind of things the reason is that
this is a different type of phone than
what we have done before because you can
see that on the right hand side you have
a function of the tuning data so
typically on the right hand side right
so the the so-called Club let's call it
classical uniform convergence
I guess you know what really uniform
confidence really mean that's slightly
kind of debatable because it depends on
how you Scope it but at least what we
have discussed in this lecture all the
bonds are doing something like this
right so the bounds before we all look
like for every Earth in some
hypothesis class f
the the law the empirical loss is less
than something like a complexity measure
of um of of capital F over square rooted
something like this
right so or you know like maybe with
high probability
something like this and all
alternatively
we can also achieve this kind of things
I think we in implicitly discuss this
right so for every Earth
L of f is less than a complexity measure
of
little f over square rooted
so so here this is capital f
so the first type is what we do exactly
you know what we got exactly from random
marker complexity because you just you
know apply random marker complexity on
it and and this is in some sense they
write the marker complexity and the
second type you can also get it by doing
a little bit things from the first type
so you can get the second type
yeah
by something like I guess this is a
remark by
considering F to be something like all
the functions where the complexity
of legal f is less than Capital C right
think of the complexity as for example
Norm of the weights when you first
Define hypothesis class where the norm
of the weight is less than Capital C and
then you apply
uh one on all on on capital f
on this hypothesis class
and then you do a unit Bond and then and
then take a union bound
on all C right so for every Capital C it
defines a hypothesis class and you
probably can write it as f
2 F Sub C right so and for this subject
F Sub C you can do the standard random
marker complexity and then you can say
that I'm going to enumerate over all
possible Capital C and then do another
layer of Union Bond on top of it we
didn't we never do this formula but this
is just one parameter you can just
discretize whatever you want
so so in some sense this is how you get
the type 1 type 2 bound but the thing is
that either of this bound on the right
hand side the bound depends on the data
the empirical data it's always a
property either of the model or of the
function class
so
so the question is you know how do you
if you want to get something like this
right like our goal today you have to do
something
kind of like more
um uh you have to include some new
techniques right so our goal right so
our goal is to get something like
I think maybe let's call this I think we
call this data dependent Bond
generalization Bond
this term might be a little bit kind of
overused in certain cases you know but
but what I mean here is that you want to
have a bond that with higher probability
for every f
your population loss is less than some
maybe complexity
of F and the empirical date
so the right hand side is also random
variable that depends on the empirical
data of course the you you're asking
this for high probability right anyways
right so you're asking that for all for
with high probability over the choice of
the empirical data this inequality is
true
and and this is useful in the sense that
you know this is useful in a still kind
of useful in a sense that
you can regularize the right hand side
you can
you can add
the rhs
as a regularizer
right so not only this is explanation in
some sense but also it can be used
actively as a regularizer because the
right transfer is something you can
optimize
right so
so this is kind of the goal that we are
uh trying to achieve
so
um and in some sense I think you know I
used to have a little argument about you
know why this is actually the right
thing to do it's kind of like cheeky
because you know uh these days still
there's no consensus on what exactly
kind of generalization you are looking
for you know I'm I believe that this is
one thing that is good to have but you
know uh but there could be other forms
of like generalization blocks
um in some sense you can argue that this
is um the best you can achieve in the
sense that you know you cannot you know
have a stronger one on the right hand
side because for example you cannot
replace this
empirical uh data by population
description right if you replace that
then you can just choose suppose you
allow the complex measure to depend on
the population distribution suppose
you allow that I can have complexity
of F and the population distribution T
then why not just Define this to be LP
of f like sorry why not to Define this
to be the population risk what if you
allow this why not just Define to be
something like tax from p
f x right so the population risk would
be a good complex measure
then it sometimes you lose the the the
gist here in some sense it becomes too
trivial and in some sense they suggests
that you're cheating in some sense by
allowing the complex measure to depend
on P so in some sense the kind of the
fundamental question we are facing about
this we are facing about in the
generalization bound is that you don't
have access to the population
distribution you want to have an
empirical measure for your complexity so
that you can use that for regularization
by the way but you know it this argument
is kind of like I know a debateful so so
for now we just say that this is a one
of the reasonable goals right so okay
and and why doing this is challenging
um
uh I think the the first thing is that
this is challenging because you cannot
do the simple reduction as as we have
done before
so so the reduction from type the
reduction
between one two
type one type two bonds uh doesn't work
anymore
foreign
for example let's define capital F to be
all the way to F such that the
complexity
um of f
X
suppose you say this is less than C
um suppose you define this right this is
your hypothesis class
and let's say suppose our we attempt to
use you know as an attempt is that you
use f
is rather marker complexity
for capital f
worst issue why we cannot do this
the reason is that
if your complex Network depends on the
data then your random hypothesis class
also depends on data before your
complexion identity depend on data your
hypothesis cost is just a fixed
hypothesis class
so so now it's a hypothesis cost that
depends on data so f is also a random
variable
depending on data
data in data means means empirical data
right and then you can use the writer
marker complexity like the theorem for
random marker complexity but why the
random Market complex debunks the the
generalization over that theorem
requires the capital F to be a fixed
hypothesis class that is fixed before
you draw the the random data
so so that's the that's the challenge
Okay so
and how do we uh adjust this so in some
sense the kind of like the the way to
the high level way to to address it is
to kind of like redefine
uh you have to have a refund way to
think about you know uh uniform convert
so some refund refund uniform converges
this is not going to be exactly what we
do like eventually because you know you
what we do eventually will be something
very clean and and doesn't have any kind
of like
kind of like personality but but this is
kind of the roughly thinking how do you
think about it so
um so maybe let's make a make assumption
these are some suppose the complexity
measure
uh is uh separable
in the sense that
this complexity of f on the empirical
example
is of some form like G of
f x i right it's really some function of
F and x i and you take the sum of them
so suppose in this special case then you
can think of
essentially what we're doing is that we
are considering
then we can consider
a
an augmented loss
so you can define something like L tilde
f is equals to
something like LF times the indicator
that is complexity
is less than C
so in some sense what you are doing here
is that you are changing the the loss
function
in some way so that it's easier for you
to use the existing bar so before for
example let's say the kind of the mental
picture I have in mind is something like
you have
um you have a loss function which is
like something like this
maybe let's say this is empirical loss
and you have some
region
and this is the region where you have
low complexity
right so but this region is a random
region because the low complexity the
definition of low complexity depends on
data so this is random
so that's why you can use the uniform
convergence only on this low complexity
region right so you cannot say that I'm
only going to apply
my uniform convergence for this region
even though that's your goal but you
cannot apply the random micro complexity
Theory so so the the kind of like the
this kind of like organic laws what is
fundamental is doing something like it
changed the geometry outside
the the low complex region so you for
example you just Define a lot newer loss
function to be zero here
and then
um I
like a the same thing as it as it was
you know in the low complex region so
now we have a globally defined loss
function and so basically the the region
that you are taking Union Bond over
right the the the the hypothesis class
is still the same but you change the
loss function
so so if you do this then you can hope
to so can hope
to apply
like existing tools
on altitude of F and l2.5 is sometimes
kind of like a filtering thing that
filters the
the
uh um the low complexity but but you
don't do it you know technically right
technically you are just changing the
loss function that's the only thing you
do but the effect of it is the same as
you change the hypothesis class
so so I think this is the first thing
like this is the first attempt that we
have done in one of our paper when we
try to address this and and and this is
actually the fundamental
um on idea in some sense so so you
change your loss function so that you
can deal with different type of
quantities of different regions of the
hypothesis and then later
um so so this is one of the paper we had
in
I think 2019
and we got some results and the the if
you exactly do this indicator thing
where you change the loss like this you
can already get something but the kind
of the the results are messy so then we
kind of like
um in some sense I think even more
broadly right so so in some sense all
this is doing is change the loss
function right so so so you are trying
to have a surrogate loss
and and surrogate loss we are not
actually unfamiliar with it right we
have used the surrogate loss in the
margin case right it's just that
surrogate loss there is kind of like
this the simplest way the simplest is
surrogates loss so so so basically what
we are um what I'm going to talk about
today you know in the main part is this
so-called you know Euler margin which is
a different way of
it's kind of like a surrogate
margin
and once you have this kind of like a
like fake margin this is a kind of in
some sense to define a new loss function
for you and once you have this new loss
function you can do everything in a
super clean way and then uh you can
um
um like you can apply the existing kind
of tools in some sense
okay so this is a kind of like a sketchy
a vague kind of introduction I'm not
sure whether any questions so far
oh sorry this is um I yeah this is the
name of the the thing we are going to
introduce but we're gonna introduce a
new margin which is we call it only
rematch
I probably should Define it formally
so
um okay so some so basically the main
point I'm doing I'm saying here is that
we have not defined a surrogate loss and
and using this surrogate loss the the
point of the target loss is to change
the original Law so that you can focus
on the important part of the space and
this target loss will be basically kind
of boring for
for this kind of like a high complexity
part right they are just they are not
doing anything they are basically
zeroing out like in some sense and so
that's the general intuition okay so now
let's see how do we do that exactly
so so we're gonna start with a
generalization
of of margin
so
um so let f
um so this is a classification model
foreign
and your margin is just F itself right
so the the typical margin
the classic the the standard margin is
just defined
a standard margin
is just equals to Y times f x
Y is between
plus one minus one right that's what we
used before
and now I'm going to define a so-called
generalized margin
we say
g f x y
is a
generalized
margin
if
satisfies
the following two properties so the
first part of it is that g f x y
is zero if you classify
correctly
it classified correctly
so I think I have typo here let me think
sorry I think
if you cast very wrongly
and this will be
larger than zero if
f x y
is classified correctly so let me
mark this important type of
sorry
okay so and you can see that you know
this is trying to imitate the the
standard margin right the first standard
margin is bigger than zero if you
classify correctly and otherwise you say
you zero it out so that's a like
external Market also this is only
defined
only defined
for correct classification
right so so in some sense you can extend
to incorrect classification just by
extending it to zero
and so and we and we say that you know
like uh and there's another small thing
which is that
we have to define the so-called you know
infinite carbon number
so um this is defined to be L Infinity
Epsilon f
is the
this is a small technical extension of
the L2 carbon number it's not that you
know important in most of the cases it
just makes the
in some sense the in some cases it makes
the definition cleaner
um and in some cases it makes the proof
a little bit easier so so our Infinity
carbon number is the minimum
cover size
with respect to the Matrix
row
your row is defined to be this L
Infinity Norm
so basically you say that you look at
the entire space
of the input of F and you look at the
difference between f x and
F Prime X and and you take the soup
so basically this is the F minus F Prime
Infinity naught
um so
okay so given these two what we'll say
is that
um our Lemma will be that
the with the you can have a analogous
um Theory analogous to the modern Theory
where you use this generalized margin
and also the infinite cover number
actually actually you can even do it
without like a standard carbon number
it's just easier to state with the
infinite cover number and also maybe
before doing that let me also have
another remark
which is that this infinite cover number
is larger than the standard
Auto covering
this is just because the
this is the more demanding notion
because you are demanding that F and F
Prime are closed at every possible input
and before you are demanding that F and
F Prime are closed on the empirical data
right so this is because
the metric that we used before
was The Matrix
that is smaller
then the Matrix used in the infinite
case
Okay so
so with this um small extension what
we're going to do is that we're going to
say actually we can have analogous
modern Theory with the generous margin
so the Lemma is that
um so suppose
GF is a generalized margin
and let's
capital G
to be the family of GF
where f is ranging over the capital n
and suppose
recall that this is kind of like what we
are kind of like a this is in some sense
just a slightly kind of like more
complex version of your model hypothesis
right like if you just use yfx then this
will just be y times f x that's the
hypothesis cause that's the class G and
this is a little more General than that
and suppose uh for some r
a covering number
the infinite covering number of G of G
is less than R square over Epsilon
Square
for Epsilon
and 0 for any Epsilon zero
or I suppose you have this kind of like
one over Epsilon Square decay in the low
carbon number recall that this is one of
the regime that we
that is good right so this is the
actually the the worst regime we can
tolerate when we do the right Market
complexity right so
and
suppose you have to understand
with probability larger than one minus
Delta the other is the failure
probability which will be hidden in the
in the logarithmic
uh over the randomness
training data
for every F in capital f
that correctly
predicts
all shiny example
right so for margin we also we for and
in the modern Theory we always consider
functions that can correctly predict all
the examples then you have the zero one
error
is less than
of
tilde of
1 over square root n times
well over the minimum generalized margin
plus altitude of one over square root
so so to recall that basically before
what we had was oh there's an R here
sorry
so before what we had was that here you
have the standard margin
standard margin
the minimum margin over the entire data
set
and here R is the complexity of the
model hypothesis class
right and all the other things are
mistake
now the change is that now
here you replace it by generalized
margin and R becomes the hypothesis
uh the complexity of the hypothesis
class of this generalized margin GF
right and the complexity is measured
slightly differently we are using the
the covering number but actually you can
also use weather marker complexity here
um it's the same I'm just stating it so
that it's easier for for the Future Part
um
and this one is actually not very tight
you can actually improve this Bond you
know in some ways
um but but that's but this is the
simplest version
and and the proof of this you know is
basically it's just we just basically we
use all what we have done with margin
Theory it's just everything seems to
just can transfer exactly so so just to
replace in some sense the proof is just
replace
the f
by G
in the margin
Theory I'll do this you know step by
step
um but but this is the short version so
so so so technically what you do is
let's still use the
the Ram plus
recall that the Run plus was the loss
function that looks like
this
where this is a gamma red
this part is gamma this part is one
something like this
and recall that before we after we have
this run plus we Define this you know
surrogate loss
right so we Define a surrogate loss our
height gamma
data to be
before we just apply it with the model
but now we use the generator smart
uh before here this was just F Theta but
now it becomes like G of f Theta G sub F
Theta and we can also Define the
surrogate population loss which is just
the expectation of the empirical loss
okay so and before what we do it is that
we use the radar marker complexity to
control the differences of these two
loss function
wow
we saw that you take L gamma
Theta is minus L height gamma Theta
is less than
the import router marker complexity of f
that's what we did before but now is to
start before we did the Imperial number
complexity of
L gamma composed with f and now it's l
gamma composed with g
because the function class the function
is different
um plus o to the Power Square 10.
sorry
oh okay thank you so much yeah that's a
so I would just switch to this
I only have one charger but yeah
uh no I think it's uh the problem is
that when you use this I cannot charge
uh right oh but I can wait it doesn't
matter how yeah it's not the charger
it's the the plug the the hole yeah okay
so now it works
okay good thanks uh okay cool so
right so
okay so so now we have to use the random
mark on Flex day and then the radamr
complexity is less than
the copying number right so I guess
maybe let's still do that let's do the
cover number
so cover number
let's do some preparation so we assume
the Infinity Property number but
actually you know
um it's
um okay I guess let's say so the
covering number the standard cover
number
composed with g
the
l2pn
this is less than this
Standard carbon number
where you use the
um
by removing the
the Algoma right so Alabama so l2pn
because this is
this step is using the Ellipsis
deliciousness
of
agama
so it's actually one over gamma Ellipsis
right so this is using the
ellipselessness of the carbon number
and now next you say this is also bonded
by the infinity version
right and and then if the infinite
version will have assumption the
Assumption was that for every episode
you this is less than R square over
Epsilon Square gamma Square
the last step is spell assumption
okay so so you can see that actually you
know even suppose you assume something
about this then it's also fun if you
receive something about
um
right so you don't have to you I
literally use the infinite note
um okay so and then because the
this low carbon number is less than this
and we have kind of like a this kind of
like translation right so that if you
translate low carbon number to random
marker complexity you got are as our
gamma composed with G is less than o
tilde
R over gamma squared
overcome scorpion right this is by
uh chaining
a w theorem and and its consequences
because we have discussed what kind of
like cover numbers replies what kind of
random marker complexity
right so okay so and
then
[Music]
the same thing I guess
take
gamma to be gamma mean
which is the Min over I
g i f
say y i
right so and then
there this step is not form this
some some there's some caveat here
because gamma is a random variable you
have to do Union Bond eventually
but let me not get into it I guess we
had this issue before as well
um but it's only one number you can
discretize and doing over gamma but
suppose let's say we just take down what
we Gamma mean and then
foreign
so then you got L 0 1 Theta then zero
plus O2 off
R over square root n times gamma mean
plus some altitude of Y squared
okay
so this proof is not 100 formal just
because the technical I'm not allowed to
take gamma to be anything that depends
on the data right so I have to really
show it for every gamma
um and that requires another inbound
overcome
foreign
so maybe let's let's see what we have
achieved with this level right what we
achieve this this Lemma is that now if
you define your
basically you can fold everything you
can try to fold everything in this
generalized market right this challenge
margin in some sense is a way to
to twist your model output right so you
can stretch the model output in for
certain F and you can squeeze it for
certain other app so in some sense this
is what we actually will do right so we
in some sense stretched the function for
those places where we'll see you you see
how we do it like you stretch the
function according to where you are at
and
um
so
so basically everything is folded into
this
um
thermos margin and the question is so
the question now is that question
so for what
GF you can you can bounce the
generalization error you can Bond the
covering number
of G right and also you want this GF to
be something with meaning of also and so
forth
so and suppose you know if you just take
GF
to be the standard one
yfx then the cover number of this GF
will be the same as current number of F
and it will be the then the rather
Market complexity will be something like
then a cover number
depends on the product
so
so but but we are trying to do better
than this
okay so how do we do this so now we
Define this so-called all layer margin
this is a special
instance of this GF this is a concrete
definition of GF for which we can Bond
the render marker or the cover number uh
complexity
so to Define this uh to Define this
Euler margin this generalized margin
right so we have to actually introduce
some notations so we are considering
some perturbed model
so I guess okay I think
maybe I think actually it's good useful
to have some motivations before I
defined I forgot to add this so
uh in the our motivation is the
following so
if you think about the linear model
and the the margin is defined to be
the the margin
the standard margin right so this like
the you like the normalized margin
to normalized margin
is defined to be something like y times
f x
over the norm of maybe it says your
model is double transpose X
so your margin is defined to be y times
the model output
over the two Norm of w
right so this is the normalized margin
which is something that's kind of like
governs uh the the generalization
performance
and the question is how do you normalize
right so so like if you have deep model
then you can try to normalize by
something right so if you have a deep
model
you can so while attempt is that you can
try to normalize
by some quantity
maybe this could be the product of the
Ellipsis Network
or maybe something else so that's the
that's the natural attempt and in some
sense all the previous work is in some
sense doing this right you are
normalizing the margin based on the
worst case slips
so and what we are doing is that we
don't know we don't want to all
normalize by only a constant that
depends only on the function class so so
we take a different approach what we do
is we say we
reinterpreted the standard margin by
something else so so we have another
interpretation
so our interpretation is that you can
view this as
something like
minimum Delta such that
w
plus Delta
um
trans sorry w
times X Plus Delta
y
is less than zero
so you're trying to find the minimum
perturbation of your data point such
that
after perturbate you can cross the the
boundary right so intuitively this is
also kind of
right because the margin is the distance
to the boundary right so it's also the
same thing as how much you can perturb
it so that you can cross the boundary
so so this is the kind of the
perspective we take to generalize the
margin for all for for deep models
so if you take this you know there's
some kind of like a small you know like
if you do the all the exact math maybe
something that match exactly but this is
still kind of like the the
the rough intuition about it and how do
we do this exactly so
um so for deep models we are still
trying to take this perturbation based
perspective but we have to perturb it
turns out we have to predict all the
all the layers not only the input so the
the first attempt we tried is that you
just perturb the input you try to see
what is the smallest perturbation of the
input so that you can change the
decision of your of your model right but
that
just technically doesn't work it it
doesn't seems to capture the fundamental
complexity so we have to consider this
um perturbed uh consider this
percept model that perturbs all the
layers
so what we do is we have a perturbation
Delta which is a cost sequence of
perturbation Delta 1 up to Delta r
and each Delta I is a vector
and the way you perturb is the following
you also have to work out the
normalization in the right way
um so your first perturb the first layer
so the first layer used to be W1
transpose x w one times x
you know deep net and you perturb that
by adding the other one which is a
vector times the norm of X the true Norm
of x
and then
you perturb the second layer
um so okay how do you predict the second
layer you first apply
W2 on the first layer on the perturbed
version of the first layer
and then you perturb it Furthermore with
Delta two and how much you perturb those
with what's the scaling in front of the
other two there are two is a vector the
scaling is the norm of the first layer
so so how do the exactly Design This
preservation is a little bit kind of
like a tricky right so like we tried the
virus versions in our research and it
turns out this is actually make
everything fade nicely so you can do
this for multiple layers and then
eventually you have this HR the OS layer
perturbed
uh layer is equals to you first apply
the nonlinear The Matrix notification
and nonlinearity
on your previous preserved layer
and then you perturb it by Vector Delta
R scaled by the norm
of the previous layer
and after you define this perturbation
you can ask you know what's the smallest
preservation that changed my decision
so you can and that's the definition of
the lower layer margin which we call an
F
X Y this is the Euler margin is defined
to be the minimum perturbation
and how do you match the size of the
pertivation you measure it by
the sum of the two Norm
of the perturbation of every layer
and your Constitution is that after
perturb
I guess you call this FX Delta this is
the perturbation of the whole model f x
Delta after perturbation times y
it becomes negative so incorrect
prediction
you can also do this for multi on labels
but it's essentially the same so I'm
doing binary labels
okay so this is the definition of the
all layer margin so you can you can see
that the definition becomes much more
complicated but then the proof of it
will be easy
and I guess you can also intuitively
interpret this right so so M as X y
so in some sense this is big
if
uh if it's hard to perturb right so if
it's hard to preserve it's hard to
change
hard to change
decisions of the network and how how
could it be hard I think there are the
two ways to make it hard to perturb
right so one thing is that
um the model f is ellipsis
and this means that it's very Ellipsis
so this means that you have to perturb a
lot to to make a big difference of your
a big change of your model output right
so and another possibility is that your
FX just is large
in some sense your standard margin is
large if a standard margin is large you
have to change a lot right you also have
to change a lot because before you're
outputting something like positive where
FX is very big and now you have to
change it to another side of the
boundary so then you have to perturb a
lot
right so or maybe I could I could say F
like y f x y times f x is large
so
typical I also I always talk about about
why is one so so positive means that you
are very confident about your prediction
and if you're very confident then it
means you have to change perturb a lot
so that you can change your
um change your mind right so that the
model can change it so much
right so and here loves us you know
technically this is lip system in the
intermediate variables
intermediate intermediate layers
because you are measuring
how robust it is to perturbation but the
perturbation is done on the intermediate
layers
but Ellipsis needs in the intimidate
layers it turns out that it's actually
close to lapuousness
with respect to parameters LL discuss
that in a moment
Okay so
and and once you have all of this so
then you have the following theorem
so this is saying that with high
probability
um l01 f the zero one Arrow of f is less
than o tilde of
the following we have one over square
root 10 first and then you have sum of
this is the so-called one one Norm of w
which I'm going to Define your moment
and also minimum I
am f x i
why I
plus o tilde of
R over squared
where
is the sum
of
absolute values
branches
w
I guess the in some sense you know we
are in a method that anything polynomial
in the norm doesn't really matter so
doesn't matter that much so so so this
is uh in some sense you just consider it
as polynomial but of course you know you
can also talk about you know whether
this one to one comma one Norm is the
right choice of the norm in some sense
this is
not the best Norm we can hope for so so
there's still some have room for
improvement here
um
but I guess you know suppose you ignore
anything polynomial Norm so then what's
important hitting here is the this all
layer margin here so basically this is
saying that if the Euler margin
is
always big then your generation is good
if the other model is smaller then your
generalization is bad and what's all
your margin all the margin is about the
perturbation your business to the
intermediate layers so this is saying
that if you're robust to perturbations
robust to perturbations
in intermediate layers
and that implies that you have good
generalization
and you can also compare
this with the bond that we've got before
you can pretty much argue that this is
strictly better than before
um so so
um so basically so compare
because is this the right place for us
to fix us
I guess let me discuss this you know
comparing with the pre-response later uh
when I'm doing all the all kind of
remarks about this theorem but but you
can show that this is
um better than the previous one mostly
just because
um this MF
in some sense this mfxy
it's kind of like roughly speaking you
can think of it this as
so like in the in the worst case
I think this is smaller
because maybe
is smaller than well over
effects
something like this right so because
this is ellipselessness and this is how
much you have to change your output you
have to change your output from FX to
zero right so and and and this is our
lipstickness so that's why you have to
change you have to make a big movement
to to change it to change FX from
something like positive or negative to
zero and and uh and and and and
wait my bad I think I sorry I think I
I'm doing the
should be this
um and
um
and so that's why this is kind of better
than the previous Bond because the
previous Bond didn't consider the
different preciousness a different data
point but here you are really talking
about you know if your lips at the data
point you have seen then you can uh
generalize code well
um but maybe let me discuss this more I
think
yeah let me have a more thyroid
discussion about this like later I just
don't want to I want to have a show a
little bit of this just so that you
don't feel like this is a huge response
um but maybe bear with me and just
assume this is useful and then we can
discuss all the interpretations
any questions so far
oh well I'm doing
fine
okay okay so we have 30 minutes
okay so let's just dive into the proof
so
um I guess the proof requires you know a
few steps but um a few small steps so
first of all it's it suffices to
to bond
foreign by
of
this
by the way I think I have some
sorry I think I have some typos here
don't
I think this should be this
this should be this
I'll double check it later
because it's always a polynomial so I
didn't really pay too much attention but
I think this is a type of
um so so so so I think you only have to
show this
okay
um
sorry I don't know I I don't know really
what this
I was gonna scrub no take out a
clarification about this I think I don't
know exactly where the square is applied
inside or outside
um but anyway you have to show some Bond
like this right so let's assume this is
the correct amount and then you
basically have to show something like
this
um because if you have this then you can
use dilemma before and then on the
challenge margin you get this random
marker this standardization ball all
right so essentially we just have to
bounce the cover number of t and it
turns out that the carbon number of G
you have uh this very nice decomposition
name on so let's say let f i
Define each layer
the hypothesis cost for every layer
right and we also constrained that wi
one comma one Norm is less than beta I
okay so then your your if is really f r
composed with f r minus 1 up to F1 this
is the notation we have used and recall
that we had a
kind of a decomposition limit before
which was kind of complicated right so
you have all of these dependencies and
how the error propagates but now dilemma
is pretty simple
cool
so so let's
I'm composed with f
denote
its family
of the earlier margin
foreign
[Music]
the log
of the infinity carbon number
where the radius is just simply the sum
the average in some sense a quadratic
average of the radius on each layer
and you care about the generalized
margin this is less than the sum
of the log
if you know probably number of Epsilon I
have to f i
so so in some sense this is saying that
you only have to deal with the cover
number for every layer and then you got
a cover number for the composed function
class
but you don't get the cover number for
the compose function class exactly you
get the cover number of the Euler margin
of the composed function class
so and here
this early Infinity Epsilon if I
is defined
with respect to the input so there's the
input domain to Define this
common number right so the input domain
X which is the the the one not the true
Norm ball is less than what
and so I guess the one of the important
thing is that this is not uh this is an
and right this is the Euler margin
Okay so
on the Corollary
is that
if
each of the layer you can bounce
the cover number by something like Ci
Square over Epsilon y Square suppose you
can bound this
let's use letter C here
so then
take
Epsilon to be Epsilon times c p i over
sum of square roots C Square
so I is equals this
then we have
log
infinite Epsilon you have the carbon
number of the compose model
is less than
sum of c i Square over Epsilon Square
so which means that suppose you believe
CI is a complex measure for each of the
layer then you can get the complexity
for the composed model the Euler margin
of the compose model
the complexity will be just the sum of
CI score
yeah I think
I think I know
I didn't have an error here I think this
is indeed
something like this
yeah this was correct
sorry
Okay cool so
and you see I will be something like see
I will be something like the w i
one comma one Norm and that's how you
go through all these things
right so so basically you know we will
show we can show
I think I will improve this but this is
not this is all because this is for one
layer right so we assume you can
basically you know you can believe that
you can basically invoke a theorem for
linear model together so indeed it's
true so for linear models
um you get something like this
and beta I was the bond on the so we
call that beta I was the bound on the
one comma one Norm of WI
and this will this will imply the main
theorem
okay so I think I hope I convinced you
that basically as long as you prove this
decomposition level then you are done
because you
for the right hand side you invoke
something about linear model and then
you plug in Islam or you get the cover
number bounds for the all layer margin
and then you get the
original zero using the the lemon I have
shown before about the generalized
margin
Okay so
any questions so far
foreign
[Music]
for the concrete fi right which is the Z
map to Sigma w i z
you can also have you can State the
landmark in a more general form and also
you can prove it in a more general form
but I'm only going to prove it for this
particular family of F5
um and so the first step is that so so
we'll show so the so the two steps
step one
uh we show that mfx
is one ellipsis
are in
f
and what one loop 16 f means is the
following
so for every Earth an F Prime
MF X Y minus f f Prime x y
it's less than
in some sense the luciousness of every
layer so you have all layers so this is
some from one to R
and
you take the max
of f i x minus f i Prime X
to know X
is so so here f is equals to f r
composed with f r minus 1 up to F1
and F Prime is
FR Prime composed with f r minus one
F1 Prime
so basically the largestness of this
Euler margin is
something that doesn't have actual scale
in some sense because you are looking at
the
uh this
this no no this power with no scale and
also it only depends it's basically the
sum of the ellipselessness
or the sum of the
um the differences between F5 and F5
Prime right so so there's no multiplier
here right you are not multiplying on
the the ellipselessness of f right so
it's really literal stuff it's very
clean
um and let's prove this step one um uh
your moment but suppose you have step
one then you what you can get
is that you can use step two you can use
this step one just to get uh the theorem
relatively easily what you do is you say
now you construct a cover
construct
a cover
and how do you do that you the cover is
the construction is also kind of show
you so what you do is you let
U1 up to u r b Epsilon 1 up to Epsilon R
cover
of uh F1 up to fr
respectively
and recall that you know if you still
remember what DVD last time the covering
was very complicated right so you
iteratively construct covers and make it
you know very complicated but now we
just individually construct covers for
every fi
and then and then we say UI such that UI
is equals to this
the infinite Norm carbon number
and
um and then
so so this means that you know by
definition right so we got that you know
for every
fi
in capital f i there exists some
function UI in capital UI
such that
f i minus UI
is small right so and I guess we are
using this metric this if Phenom metric
f i x minus u i x
to none
is smaller than Epsilon this is window
by definition
and now we're going to turn this into a
cover for the compose the family so and
the cover is just a so we just take
the U to be the family of just the
composition of all of this
the conversation of u r composed with U
or minus 1 composed with U1 which is
foreign
and this is will be our cover and we'll
show this is will be shown
will be our cover
for
M composed with f and why that's the
case this is because suppose we are
given
f is equals to FR compose
up to F1 in capital f
you you are up to you one
be the nearest neighbor
's neighbor
of f r up to F1
so then
as you can see that using this
ellipselessness
this minus and
as a u is equals to u r composed
with 0 minus 1 up to U1 so look at this
so suppose you do this this is less than
using our step one
sum of
the difference between if I and UI
the worst case difference between them
over the normal one
and because F and U are closed that's
how we constructed the cover so we get
square root sum of Epsilon I Square
and from 1 to R
okay
so so basically you know once you have
this such a nice ellipselessness
so kind of lepslessness property then
you can just cover everything
individually and you don't have to think
too much about conversation the
conversations to you because it's deal
with this it's dealt with but
so so now and now why deluxiousness
holds so let's prove step one
so and so we only approved the upper
bounds so we want to prove
this by symmetry
right because I find F Prime have the
same row so you can only have to proof
one side and you can flip them together
other side
and
it sometimes the way to prove it is just
really each of them is defined by some
optimization program right and there are
the solutions the optimal value of the
optimization programs right basically
you're trying to show the two
optimization programs are doing similar
stuff
um and how do you do that hey people you
construct optimal solution of one
optimization program into a speedable
solution to other optimization program
that's how you relate to optimization
programs so so let Delta one store up to
Delta R star
the the optimal
choice
of Delta
uh
in defining
MF x y
so and we want to turn so our goal
is to turn this into Delta one
height there's our gamma
of feasible solution
of MF Prime x y
right so if you have a if it's a
feasible solution you get NF Prime x y
is less than sum of
Delta I hat Square
and then you can relate this to
sum of Delta I using your Construction
right so
okay so that's the rough idea
and how do we construct this the other
one hand up to build the r height so
so we wanted it to be feasible so that
we can have this inner Corner this part
is going to be the feasibility part so
so basically the way we do it is that we
want to construct
so we want to make
of
Prime with the other one had up to Delta
R hat
doing the same thing
as as and with the other one star up to
Delta R star
so basically on the perturbation on F
Prime to do the same thing as
perturbation
the the perturbation of data I star on F
so that then you know that this will be
a feasible solution because what's the
feasibility the feasibility is about
whether you perturbed the prediction to
to the other side right so if this this
one can perturb the prediction to change
the prediction to the other side then
the other one also change the position
because they are doing the same thing
that that's the the the the the the the
principle and how do you do that it's
just pretty much just algebra right so F
has parameter
that's a parameter W1
after WR
and F Prime has parameter W1 Prime up to
w r Prime
and let's consider the computation right
so
um
I guess the
the in the competition is this right so
H1 is equals w1x plus Delta one star X
S2 is equals to Sigma W 2 H1 plus Delta
2 Star
H1
so and so forth HR is equal to Sigma w r
h r minus 1 plus Delta R star
h r minus one so this is the computation
you did for
this is the computation for
for m f x y right so and I want to
imitate this computation by perturbing F
Prime in some way and how do we imitate
that so the imitation is kind of trivial
so imitate this
so what you do is you say you take
so for f Prime what happens H1 is equals
to W1 Prime X plus something right
plus and how do so and you suppose you
predict the other one star X then it
wouldn't help
because this W1 Prime is different from
W1
right so you have to predict something
new addition to make this computation
the same as before and how to do that is
you perturb in addition
W1 minus W1 Prime X
and then these two are literally exactly
the same
so basically you declare this as my new
preservation you declare this has to be
now Delta one hat
times x
to know
so so basically compensate the
difference between W1 and W1 Prime by
adding this additional perturbation
so that means that Delta 1 Hat is equals
to Delta 1 Star Plus W1 minus W1 Prime X
over the two Norm of x
and you do the same thing basically for
every layer so now H2 you want H2 to be
equal to the same H2 above but your
first step is
your only product being based on W1
Prime you are not pretending based on W2
so you are only practicing based on W2
Prime but not based on W2 so what you do
is you first perturb the original one
the one it gives us two star H1
and then you compensate the div
by perturbing even more
something like this and you declare this
entire thing will be defined to be Delta
2
h
one to naught and that means that the
other two that you had that you had will
be the other one two star
Plus
Something Like H one two Norm
uh and the denominator will be Sigma W 2
H1 minus Sigma 2W 2 Prime H1
I guess you do the same thing for every
layer and in general
you just take Delta I hat to be Delta I
Star Plus
Sigma w i h i minus 1 minus Sigma
wi Prime h i minus 1
over h i minus one
and now we've got the same we got our
goal so basically Delta one hat
on F right on F Prime is the same doing
the same thing as Delta 1 up to Delta r
um I'm using this short answers too
to save some time in writing so I'm
saying that basically I'm saying you
perturbed the Delta one has up to the r
height from F Prime it's doing this
exactly the same functionality the same
prediction as the other one so that
means that we this is a feasible
solution this is a feasible solution for
MF Prime so that's why MF Prime x y
is less than the sum of
Delta I had two Norm square square root
and now this is
uh this is equals to
I guess I'm going to bound this by
square root sum of
the entire star to Norm square plus
square root sum of the differences
between them
and this is using the so-called
[Music]
this is using the so-called mink misconf
I guess
I I always think of it as cautious words
but I think there's a technical name
which is called means minkowski
inequality
in the quality so what he's doing is
that
say stay in the following so if you look
at
square root
of the sum of a i plus b i to Norm
Square
it says less than square root sum of a i
Square
and square root sum of bi
to Norm squared
so this is the mean meaning of
inequality and actually you can prove
this inequality by cosine squares by
just X you take the square on both sides
and cancel Bank of terms and it becomes
course insurance
um all right okay so so we apply this
when where AI is Delta I Star right AI
is Delta I star and b i
is is this thing it's the diff between
note
I think five percent is enough for me
okay yeah uh okay cool so uh yeah I
think one minutes per percentage
okay uh okay so now let's see so and
this one is the
MF of X Y
and on the other one you can bound it by
the this is
I guess this is literally uh
you can bound this by
square root sum over I from 1 to R
the max over
X
in one norm and sigma w x minus Sigma
I prime X
Square
right just because this whole thing is
homogeneous so dividing by the true Norm
is the same as restrictment to Norm to
be one
right so and then this is equals to MF
of X Y
plus square roots
sum over r
Max
x 2 non less than one f i x
minus f i Prime X
squared
and this is what we want it for for step
one
foreign
[Applause]
W
is the parameter for f and double Prime
is the parameter for f Prime
and they don't have
at least in this contact they don't have
any relationship because I'm just trying
to show that I'm trying to show this
stuff right this step one
so I'm taking two arbitrary F and F
Prime and I want to say that the the
Euler margin difference difference in
order margin is bonded by a difference
in each of the layers right so it
doesn't matter what they are
yes
so F Prime involves all the wi primes
and F involves all the Wis
foreign
okay cool any other questions
[Music]
okay yeah so so this
um you know if if I'm guessing the
question I think all of this depends on
the definition of MF yes of course
um and and it's actually when we do the
research I think it's that we are trying
to meet in the middle like you have to
change the definition in a way so that
the analysis is okay
um
but in some sense this is in some sense
because the proof is Simple and Clean so
somehow I feel good about the definition
to some extent
um
yeah so I guess I'll use the next few
minutes and the four percent of battery
uh to to talk about some of the
comparisons interpretations and
our next possible extensions
so
um
I think I guess interpretation I kind of
like
um in some sense I've discussed this a
little bit so the most important thing
is the Euler emerging part at least
that's our main side you know and we
don't even care about the norm so and so
you can you then you can compare with
compare with
bar trade at all
17 is the paper that we discussed last
time so you can formally do this where
you can formally say that the perturbed
model
if you look at the difference between
the preferred model and the original
model
the difference is something
like if you do a some kind of like
telescoping
thing
this is supposed to be not super hard so
you can basically kind of Imagine That
for every layer you you perturb
something so you pay something like that
and then you have a you also have to pay
the blowing up Factor because of the the
other things right so you can prove this
all right
so if you kind of like you know ignore
some ignoring some Minor Details which
you know allows me to have a cleaner
extra position
um so for example you ignore dependency
on r
then you can basically say that you know
if maybe let's also supposed Y is bigger
than zero
that's for simplistic say Y is one
then basically if you want to if you
want f x to be bigger than zero and F X
Plus Delta to be less than zero right
that's kind of like a what
the situation would be right well you
perturb the your model to predict the
wrong thing and and then this means that
you know your Delta
needs to be basically something
larger than the product of the spectral
Norm
because you know
at least right because you know uh
that's how you can make enough
difference right so if your Delta is too
small then the right hand side will be
too small so that you don't really make
them big enough of difference
so and times FX
right so
um so so that's that's it that's it
saying that basically
uh in some sense this is saying that m f
x y
or Y times f x right the new margin
versus the old margin the ratio is
something like this
I'm writing this you know in some kind
of like in somewhat informal way so I'm
ignoring constant not even going some
kind of like small Minor Details I think
this product probably shouldn't probably
range from one to R it should miss some
terms in the middle but those are not
super important and and this is
basically saying that you know if you
look at the inverse margin this is kind
of like FFX
times the product of the spectrum
so
so this is indeed a better bound than
before because you you approve the our
new Bond depends on this and all the
bond depends on this on the right hand
side times the spectral
so so this is a better bound
at least in this aspect
um and
and another thing is that you know later
um but but why this but this but why
this is you know how how much better it
is when compared to the previous one
that's uh that's a that's a question
mark right so so is it true that your
order merge now becomes like polynomial
instead of like exponential
um there are some indicators that this
is a much better Bond empirically like
all like or conceptually
um empirical we did verify it seems to
be much better like the number becomes
smaller but just because in parallel
your your lips your lipsense is better
than the worst hit spot another reason
why you can somewhat hope that the
imperial this is better is because later
we'll show
I think I've said this once before but
let me spray down again so SGD prefers
uh lipstick Solutions
and and in some sense on data points and
ellipses on data points
in some sense this is saying that no
your algorithm in some sense is
minimizing the leftist-ness on the data
point so that's why you you your lips
just on the data point is probably
better than the worst case lipstickness
of the entire domain and that's probably
why the gap between these two bounds are
significant
um so so in some sense you are implicit
so this in some sense this is very
implicitly
minimizing
maximizing the Euler margins
so but this of course this is
approximately because you know
all of this kind of like what icg
prefers you know in terms of the form
we'll see is similar but uh but they
won't be exactly matching the same form
so so we haven't got a fully kind of
like a
um coherent story Theory yet but by
conceptually they are they all seems to
properly match and another thing is that
there's something which actually people
actually use in practice which is called
San this is called sharpness
aware
regularization
this is something that can let you to
get better performance empirically on
many data sets
um and and what they are doing is that
they are doing perturbation
so we are doing a preservation but they
are also doing perturbation but they are
preserving the parameter
Theta so they're trying to make this
model more ellipses in the parameter
Theta instead of more ellipses in the
more ellipses in the hidden variable the
intermediate variable H I's but actually
these two are very related so so here is
a fact
if you look at the laws with the
greeting of the laws with respect to the
uh the parameter WI this is equals to
the grid of laws with respect to
I'm always this is now a single example
always on a single example
this is the equals to the green of the
laws resurrects to
to the
um
uh to the hidden variables
in the layer above and times the hidden
variable transpose
so this is just a just a
just by derivation okay actually this is
used to call
a black kind of name like a
um
like in neural science there's actual
term for this this thing like but this
is just literally just a you can feel
the gradient of wi how you do it you
just change one you get this
so so here this is the green with a
cleaning variable and this is the size
obtaining verb so if you look so that's
why if you look at a norm of the
the the Grid in respect to the parameter
then it's quite related to the norm of
the gradient
with respect to the hidden verb
this is a vector this is a vector and
this is a matrix so so so that's why
this is true
um so let's just in parameter is similar
to ellipselessness in Hidden variable
it's somewhat related
okay so the first the last thing I guess
I'm running out of time sorry so
um this is a more General version
where you don't have to care about
the minimum margin over the entire data
set you can prove something like test
our
is less than
one over square root n times instead of
the average the this is average margin
instead of like the worst case smart the
the minimum margin of the data set so
you look at the average inverse margin
of this form
and then times the
sum of complexities
of each layer
so
um and plus lower the term
oops oh really
of course
it can really okay five percent is not
enough okay but this is literally the
last last thing I want to say
um
um yeah
are there any questions
[Music]
so so basically the last thing I want to
say is that you know like instead of
having a minimum like all your margin
there you can have the average earlier
March
two
um
okay uh any questions
okay I guess then see you next Monday or
Wednesday in two days okay wait today's
Monday right okay okay
two bye thanks